so have you guys noticed that Superbook
sort of sounds I don't know kind of
weird when you re-watch Dragon Ball Z
now well maybe you could notice the
difference here
I recognize you now you're one of the
ones I've beaten before
ones I've beaten before did you catch it
in case you didn't his current voice
sounds way higher pitched than it
originally did originally they actually
used a voice pitch filter to make super
boost voice lower and scarier sounding
like the opposite of the pitch up effect
that South Park uses but for whatever
reason when FUNimation started putting
out all their season releases for the
show one of the many audio changes they
made included getting rid of this filter
why did they do it I have absolutely no
idea is it necessarily objectively worse
well not really I guess what do you guys
think